人間の耳っていうのは音を受けて物質的な変化をするようになってるんですね
だから人は寝ていても
寝ていなくとも 耳が物質変化しちゃうんです
物質変化しちゃうと 心にはなかなか寝ていられなくなっちゃう
それに反応しなくて それで
じゃあ耳に反応しようと
それで五門陰天が生まれちゃうんです
目からいろいろ情報入っちゃうと
目の中で物質的な変化が起こるでしょうに
ですから そこでもう心には落ち着いていられなくなっちゃうんです
で 反応を起こし始めちゃうんです
瞑想していると いろんなこと気になるのはそういうわけなんです
何か音が耳に入ったら
まあそれ放っておけばいいんだけど
聞かない 聞かないでいればいいんだけど
自分の瞑想さえすれば
やっぱり耳で変化を起こしちゃうんです
耳の中で 変化を起こしちゃったら落ち着いて瞑想できなくなっちゃうんです
それで一旦心は寝て 有分身になって耳に行くんです
五門陰天を作っちゃうんです
作って音を聞く 聞いたところでまた意識に戻るんだから
音を聞いてるところじゃない
瞑想いてるところだとわかって
それでまた瞑想に戻ったりするんです
随分早くそういう出来事起こるんです
ですから この寝ている心
いわゆる有分身に 次に異聞陰天か五門陰天が出ているから
そこで意識の流れが始まります
ですから 陰天心は二つですね
それから見る 聞く 嗅ぐとかね
味わうことと触れること
それから決めることとかね
そういう働きも心にあるんですね
その場合は心は決まっていて
決める まあ慚愧ってのっていうのは受けるんですね
漏出 そこでなんで場所と言ったんですかというと
これ時間と場所両方 いつでも付いてるわけです
ある ある時間である場所にこの心が生まれるという働き
そこら辺ちょっと複雑かもしれませんだけど
そこでこの異聞陰天という
物事を考える時生まれる心が
この眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報はどんな情報かと確認するための作る
する 起こるんです 眼耳鼻舌身から情報入ったら
見たそれで終わり 何を見たかわからない
聞いたそれで終わり 何を聞いたかわからない
そこで聞いてからまた意識が働いて
ヴィパッサナーの言葉を使うならば妄想が働かせて
あ こういうことを聞いたと
こういうものを見たと判断するんです
ですから 判断するのは心なんです
異聞陰天から判断の働きが生まれる
それは純粋に意識の働きなんです
ですから 目で綺麗なものを見るんではなくて
意識で頭の中で綺麗だと判断する
綺麗な音を耳で聞いているわけじゃなくて
聞いた音を綺麗だと意識で判断する
それは科学的な説明と全く同じなんですよ
綺麗か綺麗じゃないかと判断するのは脳の働きであって
目から入る情報は脳に入るとバラバラ無茶苦茶分解して脳に
色は別なところに行っちゃうし
色も色の具合によって one箇所で全部色を理解するんじゃなくて
もう脳が その人の脳が随分勝手に細胞決めちゃうんですよ
この細胞で赤い色を決めようと
この細胞で黄色い色を決めようと
みんなどんな人間にも馴染みないんです
だから色を識別する場所にしたっても
そこで細胞の配列はそれぞれ人によって違うし
そこで形は横線か縦線かとかね
それもある場所で別々にするんです
横線認識するところは横線だけ
縦線認識するところは縦線だけ
で そういう情報バラバラになってくれたところで
また他のところで情報をあっちからこっちからいろんなところからもらって
頭の中でイメージ作っちゃうんです
我々はそのイメージで生きるんです
だから ある人を綺麗と見るものは
ある人にとっては綺麗じゃないと
ある人の美しい音は ある人にとっては美しくはないんです
ある人においしい食べ物は
もう一人の人にはおいしくはないんです
食べ物はよく分かりやすいです
それぞれ文化とかいろいろな違うものを食べているでしょうに
中国人も韓国人も日本人もアジア人もいろいろ自分の食べ物あるんですよ
小さい時それ食べさせて美味しいだろうと
刷り込まれちゃうんです
そこで脳が別においしい
おいしくないとか全然わからないんだけど
この子の味はおいしい味だと一つのイメージ作っちゃうんです
その人にとっては この食べ物はおいしいんだというふうに習慣がつけてきてつけちゃうんです
それはあの実験があって
パキスタン人かな 飼っていた犬と日本人が飼っていた犬にご飯あげたんです
日本人が飼っていた犬に
味噌汁と一緒に混ぜてご飯あげたら食べたんです
パキスタン人が食べなかった
カレー味にカレーと混ぜてご飯あげたら
パキスタン人の犬は食べたんだけど
日本の犬は食べなかった
で それでまあ育てる人が味を教えて教えられていることなんです
基本的には体に餌が必要ですね
その時はもらった餌を食べるんです
それでお腹が空いている
お腹が消えてしまいますから
それで気持ちいいんだと判断するでしょう
それで気持ちいい判断とこの味と一緒に混ぜて特別なイメージ作っちゃうんですね
犬の頭の中に そこでそれはもう食べ物が
猫っていうのはもう魚食べるのも決まってるんだけど
野菜だけ食べる猫もいるんです
自分の国でいたんです
いろいろおばあちゃんたちが飼っていた猫で
おばあちゃんたちはもう彩色しすぎて全然食べない
で 保護から小さな猫にも助かって
もうもう拾ってもらったら
もう小さい時はミルクとかあげますけど
大きくなってくると固いものを食べるようになっちゃう
自分食べるものをあげるんです
それだけ食べちゃうんです
そこで魚食べない 野菜食べる
普通考えればおかしいでしょう
ですが それはないんです
僕もものすごい小さい時覚えてるんです
なんか猫が餌あげても食べなかったんだけど
おばあちゃんがいいよ
そんなもの食べませんよと
この葉っぱを炒ったまま油入れないで
こうやるという料理方法があるんです
いろんな野菜の葉っぱ種類をね
細かく刻んでただいるんですね
まあちょっとした味を入れて
まあ糖質とかなんとかって油は入れませんだけど
全く使わない 瞬時に料理はできますけど
かなり私はすごくそれ美味しいと思いますけどね
で 水分も何も手もかからないし
いろんな香辛料とか何も使わないんだから
一番簡単な料理としてなかなか評判は良くない
で まずい まずいじゃなくて
貧しい料理だと で 私が自分の考えってそれは一番いい料理ではないかと
自分は食べてるんだけど
犬猫はそれはもう全く食べる
思うでしょ 葉っぱだから結局は
葉っぱ通して見えませんだけど
ものすごい細切れにすごく細く切るんです
であのおばちゃん言ったら
それ特別な名前あります
それと一緒に混ぜてあげてみたら？言ったら
それでこの葉っぱと一緒にご飯混ぜてあげたら食べるんですね
やっぱりその猫はその食べ物にも美味しいとも
決めてるんですね イメージ
ですから 我々人間であろうとも
大体そういう風にイメージを作って生きてるんです
だからあまりそんなに気にしなくてもいいとね
技術の世界 心理の世界は全く違うんだと
例えば刺身なんか美味しいって言ったって
どんな味でしょうかね
僕らは 僕らの文化っていうのはすごい味にこだわるでしょうし
カレーもいろんな種類だから
これ各家庭によって味が違うし
そのその使う料理によってこのカレーの組み合わせが変わるんですよ
だから大変難しいんです
ただ 醤油やら砂糖やらなんとかでそんな簡単じゃないんです
魚にしたっても 魚の種類によって入れるカレーの粉の調合は違うんです
ですから この私たちにとっては
何か料理見たら その料理はこんな味だと
例えばカボチャの料理作ると
もう味の組み合わせは全く違う
カボチャ作るカボチャのカレー作る方法を教えたら
その方法でジャガイモのカレー作ったら食べられないんです
違うんです ジャガイモも向こうも全部カレーにするんだから
ジャガイモのカレーがあるし
カボチャのカレーがあるし
豆にしたっても それもカレーにするし
キャベツにしてもカレーにするし
でもカレーといってもこういう風にドロドロしたカレーではないんだけど
キャベツは葉っぱそのまんまでますけど
結局味はカレー味なんです
でも調合は全部違うんです
それで僕らは味 美味しいと決めるのは
だから舌で決めちゃうんですよ
そこでアジア人とインド人にとって
スリランカ人にとって
この刺身美味しいですよと言ったっても
びっくりする 何の味か
でも日本人にとっては全く違うんです
このマグロはすごい美味しいんですよ
言ってはマグロからすると
これお寿司マグロでしょうと
だから味が同じでしょうと
それはマグロの料理の場合は決まってるんです
どんな組み合わせするのかと
だから一応こういう風にカレーにしたら
こんなこういう味でしょうということになっちゃうんですね
ですから そこら辺 技術性っていうのはないんですね
やっぱりそのその国の人に作ってくれたイメージで
まだ想像してるんです
だからイメージはもういくらか抑えておくと
かなり幅広く味わえることはまた可能なんですけどね
イメージ食べない 食べないことにしたら
結構何でも食べられる可能性もあります
そういうことで この眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報はどんな情報かと判断するのは意識の世界
慰問点 だと仏教で言っている
イメージとかそんなことは仏教でないんです
慰問点が出てきて 目から入った情報について慰問点が出てきて
それから妄想が働かせちゃう
妄想が働き始める 妄想とは言いにくいんだけど
意識が働き始める 美味しいかないか
嫌いか好きか どっちかとか
だからカルマ起こるのは全部意識の中なんです
目でカルマは生まれません
手でカルマはすることできません
我々は手で上げたのではないかとか
手で人を殺したのではないかとか
そういうんじゃないんです
体でカルマをすることはできないんです
カルマは心に生まれるものです
だからカルマということは
業ということは 純粋に心の働き
意識の働き だからいいカルマすることも悪いカルマをすることも可能なのです
なぜならば いいことを考えることも
悪いこと考えることもいつでも可能なんですから
例えば人にご飯をあげて
もうこれ食べて消えてしまえと
もう二度と来るなという怒りの意識を作ることもできるし
食べてすごく喜んでくださいという風に
その人に対して慈しみの心を作ることもできるんです
だからご飯あげたいいカルマだよとは言えません
どんな意識を使ったかということによって
悪いカルマかいいカルマかと決められるんです
人をダメにするためにも人に寄付することできますからね
必要なもの何でもあげると
借金したら大丈夫大丈夫
私が任せておりますから
すごい善人のように見えますけど
もしかしたらその人はこの人は徹底的にダメにしようという気持ちでやる可能性もあります
ですから 例えば若い人々は成長してくれるためにいろいろ苦労させるとかありますから
そこで苦労する 苦労させるのはもう嫌でやってるわけじゃなくて
やっぱり本人が苦労して
自分でその状態を乗り越えなきゃ一人前になれないよと思ってやらせる場合は
心の中の働きはその人の幸福というイメージですから
それはいいカルマになっちゃうし
具体的にはその人は苦労しているかもしれませんだけど
料理作ってくれなかったと
自分で作れと 人は自分で作るんだけど
作ったことはないんだけど
なかなかうまくいかなくて
もう自分も切ったりとかね
また作った料理ももうお醤油入れすぎてとかね
食べなかったとか それは見ている人にとってはかわいそうやと感じるかもしれませんね
それでも我慢すると そういうふうに行動で
行動だけ見たら まずいものを食わせてるんではないか
とんでもないことでしょうと
例えば母親が自分の娘にそういうふうにさせたんだと
どうせ娘さんがそれから料理する人生にならなきゃいけないってこと
おばあちゃんもかわいそうよ
娘さんが食べられない人だから
じゃあこれ食べなさいと言ったところで
ちょっと問題がね もう混乱しますけど
ですから この行動で決めるんじゃなくて
カルマは心で決めると
とにかく でも その中でも行動で確実に決めるものがあるんです
殺すこと 殺すことは怒りでしか殺せないんです
殺すことは体でやることなんですけど
その殺される生命が生命のことを慈しみで思って
幸福でいてほしいと 長生きしてほしいと
元気で明るく生きていてほしいと思って首を絞めることはできないんです
だから全ての殺生は怒りなんです
だからこの その場合は行動パターンが決まってるんです
例えば人のものを取ることは泥棒なんですけど
ただ単に人のものを取ったんだからって泥棒したことにはならない時も結構あるんですよ
で 例えば子供がもうコンピューターゲームばっかりやってるんだけど
子供は自分のものだからやめなさいと言ってもやめないと
で 子供が学校にいるところで全部取って捨てるとか
処分したとか 子供が言ったら私のもの
私の何金ですか ポケットマネーで買ったものだから
これはもうダメです 勉強しなさいとか
人のものを取ったんではないかとお前怒ったって
別に人の取ったわけじゃないんです
あれ で あるいは人をからかってやろうとかね
心配させてやろうと思って何か取っておくとかね
それは泥棒には入りませんし
違うカルマなんですけど
その方は 何やろうともカルマにはなりますよ
心の働きているんだから
何でもカルマにはなります
やることは何でも で ありますし
我々にはやることを全部いいカルマにすることできるんです
それはもうカルマは心の
問題だから いわゆる心の概念の世界ですから
そういうこと それでそのリストはあったんでしょうね
ささ 晩餐だ その七十八ページの説明はこの瞑想の世界に必要な説明なんですけど
まあ難しいんですけど
で こういうことを言ってるんです
例えば耳があります 耳では
あの 意識ですか もう何か SOTRINA
ってパーリ語で言いますけどね
意識というものが生まれるんですね
聞いただけなんです その前に
聞く前に 五門意転が生まれるんです
五門意転が生まれて それから聞く
聞いてから 意門意転が生まれて
何を聞いたかと いろんな働きをする
頭の中で ですから 耳から
耳を通して 我々にはたくさん心が生まれる可能性あるんです
どれぐらいですか 五十四から五十五かな
五十四思われる 四十六 Panchadvāratirūpiṇā
dyavasena sotadvārasati cattāri sati Cattāri
four to sixですね
って考えてます あ four to six
そうですね 四十六種類の心が生まれるわけです
耳を通して四十六種類の心が生まれる
生まれるんです でも 耳で生まれるのはたった一つの心
他の四十五も意の中で生まれるんです
ですから 耳を通して意識の中で四十五種類の心が生まれる
同じく目を通して意識の中で四十五種類の心が生まれる
それで目の意識も入れると四十六になるわけです
まあそう分かりやすい言葉に言いましょう
音が耳で聞いたら 頭の中でそれについて考えたり
いろんなことをしたりする
そこで耳で聞いただけ
それについて頭の中でいろんな働きが生まれるんです
そこで全部心から数えると
四十六種類の心が生まれる可能性があります
四十六の中で一つは耳の心
ですから四十五中に生まれるんです
目からも同じなんです
四十六生まれる 鼻からも四十六生まれる
場所としては鼻に一つと
意に四十五個 そこで眼耳鼻舌身意も同じなんです
ですから 眼耳鼻舌身意に生まれる心は全部五十四あります
五十四と言えるし まあ五十四ですね
すべて欲界心ですよ なぜ欲界心ですよと言うですか
というと この眼耳鼻舌身意に帰っているんだから
ですから 目を通して大胆なことは理解できません
耳を通して 超越したものを理解できません
全部欲界心だけですから
欲界に 欲界というのは人間と神々と地獄の世界
その世界ですよ あまり大胆なことを理解できません
それで 意門の場合は違う
意識だけの場合は 意識だけ働かせちゃうと
扇情の心も何だか知れないようです
ですからManodvārāvā
意門においては 意門意転心
五十五の即行心 十の仮称円心による七十六の心が生まれると
意門っていうのは我々の意識ですね
意識の中でたくさん心が生まれるわけです
ですから瞑想するときはこの禅定の心とか何とか生まれるのは
目で生まれるわけじゃなくて
耳で生まれるわけじゃなくて
全部胃の中で生まれるんです
そこでアビダンマではこういうちょっとからくり考えるんですね
眼耳鼻舌身っていうのはきちんとした別々した場所なんですね
眼耳鼻舌身っていう五つがそこに在る時間で心が生まれるんであって
いつでも目で見えるわけじゃないんだから
いつでも耳で音が聞けるわけじゃないから
そこで五つの場所があるんだから
意にも場所がなければ困るじゃなくて
論理的にはね 目で見えるならば
耳で聞こえるならば 意で考えているんだと
目には場所があって 耳にも場所があって
耳という器官で じゃあ意というところはどうしようかと
だから合理的には意という器官もあった方が正しいんです
この体の中に 器官として意
物質としての意が 現代科学的に言えば
やっぱりそれは脳細胞なんですね
脳細胞とすべての神経細胞なんですね
それはただの機械 それも現代用語からいうものであって
古い仏教経典やらテキストなんかではこの場所やとははっきりしてない
それにも単なる心という言葉を使っているんです
目で見る心で考える まあそれほど厳密な科学的な言葉ではなくなっちゃうんです
それで心というのは心だから
これ心臓にも使っちゃうんですね
それで注釈書の時代になっちゃうと
これは心臓だと説明しているんです
心臓に我々の意の場所があるんだと
その説明はもうブッダが長老やら注釈書にそう言ってるんだけど
医学は発展しているんだから
心臓の中に心があるかどうかちょっと心配なんですね
心臓手術もできなくなっちゃうし
心臓手術だと全部血液を抜いてもらって
機械で血液を流れてもらっちゃいますからね
そうすると機械の中で考えてるんですかね
その人が 僕は脳にしたっても何も問題ないと思いますけどね
で だから脳だけでも人は考えることはしないんですね
神経細胞でも考えたりはする
要は判断することを考えることだから
頭に情報が行けなくたっても
反射的に体でいろんなことをすることもできますし
ですかというと それを不思議なことにおっしゃってたんです
あの時代に お釈迦様が言っているのは
意は派生 心で働いているんだと言って
心はどのものかと 心というのはどこかに人の心が働くならば
その場所に心というんだと
だからすごい曖昧な定義なんです
その曖昧な定義は 現代科学にも何も逆らうこともないんです
ですから 心が働く場所が注釈書時代で 4世紀までの時代で考えていたように
心臓であってもお釈迦様にとっては問題ないんです
今の現代医学者が いえ
脳細胞で神経細胞で判断してるのを見ても
別にお釈迦様にとってはそれは関係ない
なぜならば どこどこかに場所において位が働いているならば
その場所に心というと
言うんだから 別にこの場所やと特別な場所を決めておいてない
おそらくお釈迦様はそれを知っていただろうと思います
そうでないと そういう定義は曖昧な定義は曖昧じゃない
定義は真実の定義なんですから
ですから お釈迦様の定義から言うと
意識は考えることは体にどこにでも生まれるかもしれません
その生まれる場所を決めて
その場所に心と言ってください
言葉とはそれだけ だから未だに医学でもはっきりと決めてないんだからね
一番元に全ての行動の元になる器官はこの器官だと
そんなに決めてないんですね
脳も 1 1 1なくなっても
もう人はそれでも行動できるし
また 物好きなことの死んだっても行動できるんだから
ですから医学でもしっかり決めていないと言えば決めてないんです
ですから 眼耳鼻舌身がわかりますよ
簡単に歴とした場所がありますから
体の場合は皮膚でもうわかるし
目があって耳があって鼻があって舌があってと考える時だけにどこで考えてるんですかと
わからない わからないんだけど
瞑想する時は一つの言葉でラベリングしてもらわないと困っちゃいます
ですから  6つに分けて
眼耳鼻舌身でその色やら生まれる
意で意識が生まれる 意には物質的な意味は心というんです
それだけ それは確実に心臓でなければいけませんということではないんです
ですから その時は一般的な常識で心で考えてるんだと言った方が瞑想もしやすいし
真理に合ってるんです
心はどこですかと わかりませんと言ったらいい
そういうものもありますから
私は心で考えているんだと
あなたの心はどこにあるんです？わかりません
場所はわかりませんだけど
心で考えることだけは確かですよ
と で 本当にお釈迦様の定義っていうのは
この注釈書の定義より随分不思議なんです
なんかすごい足らないように感じますけど
どんどんどんどん追求してみちゃうと
その定義でいいんだとわかるんです
だから注釈書ではお釈迦様は心といった定義が何も物足りなかったんですね
それを明確に説明しようと言って
このテキストもあったと思いますよ
そのところで この心臓の中でほんのちょっとの欠席があって
そのこれぐらいの量 ほんのちょっとの量なんですね
そちらに心が意が働いているんだと
こちらの色の説明で心臓が出たんですね
そちらの説明読んでみてください
なんか伝統的な注釈書の伝統的な説明がそこに入っている
それはもうアビダンマ
ブッダ教徒からずっと同じです
ブッダが長老もそう思っているんです
すごい清らかな結石がほんのちょっとあるんだと
水槽の中に そこに意識が働いているんだと
これヒンドゥー教で言ってるアットマンと同じなんで
そうすると でも我々の知識にある限りは
結石っていうのは止まっているものじゃない
ずっと流れているし で
そこも結石 またずっと死んでしまうし
そこはどうかなと わかりませんだけど
それで釈迦さんの定義は何でしょうかと言えば
これはすごく不思議に
そんなくだらない人々の概念から不思議に抜けてるんです
いわゆるお釈迦様は知っていたんですよ
人間の科学的な知識というのは
その当時のものだから
それは変わるもんですよ
だから どれほど科学が発展したっても
お釈迦様がおっしゃったことは変わらないように
真理だけきちんとおっしゃっておいているんです
のがお釈迦様が自慢してるんですよ
時代は変わってみろと
法師は変わらないから
これはもう過去であろうと現在であろうが
未来であろうが この通りですよ
ですから 純粋な仏教には訂正は入れませんという
我々はものすごい厳密な態度をとっているんです
変更要りませんと 注釈要りません
解釈要りません だから仏教だったらとにかく純粋なものはいいと
古いほどものはいいという
普通の世界では新しいものは新しいほどいいんだけど
仏教の場合は古いものはいいんだと
その方が真理に近いと
我々は大乗経典はもうまるっきりもうゴミだと思って捨てるのはその一つなんです
いくら広大な膨大なテキストがあっても
全て人が勝手に付け加えて考えて考えて書いたものだから
もうゴミに近いではないか
それで大乗仏教論で見せたっても
現代科学やいろんな知識と比べると
もう全部負けっぱなしでしょうに
くだらないことをいっぱい言ったりして
ですから この釈尊の教えに近寄れば寄るほど
我々は真理に近いんです
それはもう科学的な時間
時間で変わる真理ではなくて
時間を超えている 真理にはいつでも近いんです
それはただ 真相の定義を見ただけでもわかるもんなんです
その瞬間で もうそういう当時の人々の威嚇を飛んでいるんだから
例えば宇宙の構造を説明するときでも
当時のインド人は宇宙は平らでありますと確実で決めていたんです
宇宙は平らで 水平線があって
月様やら太陽様やらもう上空を歩いているんだと
神様ですよと お釈迦様も太陽神
月の神という言葉を使ってますよ
人間の言葉だから それで宇宙の説明をすると
そういう太陽はいっぱいあるんだと
言ったところで その人々は理解しなかったと思いますよ
宇宙論は なんか変なことを言うではないけど
我々にとってはこういう空があって
天があって 太陽があって
月様があって 星があって
回ってるんだと お釈迦様はそれを見て
これあるでしょ 回りますと
そのようなものは無数にあるんだと言ったところで
現代色々な望遠鏡やいろんなものを発達して見ている宇宙はお釈迦様その通りに言ってるんです
ギャラクシーの話やら
いろんな星が集めて星団作ったりすること
それまたグルグルグルグルいろんなもの限りなくあることやら
それまた宇宙は膨張していることやら
やがて膨張して消えるんだと
それからまた始まるんだと
今の科学者たちも推定してないところまで言っていることは言ってるんですけど
当時の人々に分かりやすく言ってるんです
また でも当時の考え方にははめられないんです
ですから その知恵っていうのは
もう 2500年前だから
何の科学もなかった時代だから
虫眼鏡もなかっただろうと思いますけど
顕微鏡どころか望遠鏡のところ
そこで神は世界を創ったという話は後からでしょうね
宗教歴史から見ればね
ユダヤ教なんかはね 仏教よりは古いんですけど
旧約聖書なんかはね でも本格化れてのね
それはどんな時代かさっぱりしっかりしていないし
初めは天があって 神が光からこれを
分けてRFだとかね だから光から暗闇に分かれると
そこら辺もちょっとスッタロンニ間違いですよ
覚えてないんだけど 光から暗闇に分けた
暗闇から光に分けたかどっちか
時間になりましたので止めましょう
[椅子を動かす音]